hockey seasons tend to have their ups
and downs
and as the fall breeze gives way to a
winter chill
and the upcoming game outdoors at target
field
the minnesota wild and st louis blues
spend the week going in opposite
directions
for the blues a quick trip to florida
sees them not only lose their goaltender
to covet protocols
but both games as well
the wild however find themselves in the
middle of a winning streak their lead
growing in the central division
as we continue on the road to the 2022
nhl winter classic
it's 20 games into the season and the
minnesota wild are facing off against
the tampa bay lightning
of late the wild appear to be hitting
their stride
even without their captain 32 year old
defenseman jared spurgeon who's missed
the team's past two wins with the lower
body injury and isn't playing again
today against the back-to-back stanley
cup champs
there's always formal when you're not
playing
try
with myself being i would i think it's
tough but we have so many guys in there
that speak up and our leaders in their
own way so they take over
[Applause]
[Music]
a bit easier to see from up here down
there it's a lot quicker to
react to what's going on in rushes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
both are pretty nice shots on both goals
a 4-2 win over the two-time defending
cup champs
[Applause]
cruise around me the zamboni
seems to be more in minnesota that they
dig these out underneath the garage
[Music]
with the cold weather i think it's it's
awesome it's a bit different than
the basement i grew up shooting and so
it's pretty lucky that way
when you're injured there's a little bit
more family time so we try and do
everything as much as we can together
whoa
you're fast
[Music]
so usually his weekend days would fall
during the week and then the kids would
be at school or they have nightly
activities or something so it's been
really nice to have kind of the whole
day we can all go to hockey nothing
overlaps it's just nice
growing up with my family if i was
playing or my brother or my sister was
doing something we were there to support
each other so for us this is stuff we
like to do and we have fun with it see
how fast this week
do you think you look that fast in your
state
yeah you're that fast
minnesota's such a hockey bed for people
and to be able to have an outdoor game
and our team be playing well right now
is is obviously something special and
showcase the state the city and just how
great it is to be here i think minnesota
is a pretty hidden gem and not a lot of
people know how great of a place it is
hey go say good game
good game dude
[Music]
later in the week spurgeon is still out
but his wild are still winning their
streak now at five and about to face the
red hot toronto maple leafs
also winners of five straight
this is how you beat the leafs you drag
them into the fight big battle shift
[Applause]
tonight minnesota takes a three-nothing
lead but toronto storms back in the
second period scoring three of its own
to tie the game
oh boy it's a big game
we all know it we all know it too we're
just walking together we didn't just
lose this game in the second period so
there's 20 minutes to go stick together
in the third
neither team can find a goal
oh my god
the same with overtime
[Applause]
leading to the wild's fourth shootout of
the year
a save by talbot wins it for the wild
kneelander
[Applause]
for streaking minnesota a four-game road
trip now awaits
and we stuck together you guys played
together so great job on the day off
tomorrow
[Applause]
for the blues it's for back home perhaps
an opportunity to regain some lost
ground
on the road to the nhl winter classic
you